you
okay here we are less than three seconds
to go in the hourly bullet arena looks
like I'm gonna get paired up with Popeye
in a round one okay hmm
it's a bit of a mysterious move 92 huh
already let's just continue to develop
queenside castle let's get this in first
up 94 and Castle I could strike at that
night whenever I'm not afraid of that
move I don't know night here move
forward night here and they missed that
they're trying to line something up on
the diagonal hmm Queen takes a - pretty
strong no if the Queen ever ends up on
f4 I play Bishop d6 hmm okay good just
go here Queenie the knight is pinned
could offer a queen exchange soon maybe
take this pawn yeah let's take the pawn
Bishop b4 connect some pieces hmm let's
take care I could do that my Knights
cover
right here hmm let's give a check defend
here time burners pins could take that
they're in a pin back to tournament a
lot of pressure on their King even
though he drifted towards the Queen side
pressure on a - and now let's go E for
no I didn't mean to do that so let's
make it a king turn into a Kings Indian
attack mmm let's see if I could get an
e5 no we're not gonna be in keto we're
gonna look for a quick strike on f7
since they allowed it you know
it's crashing through here let's back up
no rush we're taking the rook let's
maintain my bishop take with the rook
night there Oh
alright let's do this now I'm on c6
let's move forward Queen here
let's castle take someone down mm-hmm
pin that night Queenie - mm-hmm let's go
here I'm hitting the knight could also
take here I don't want to waste time
even taking this take on c6 if the
knight take here 90-95 I could just take
and make threat soon or getting there
that looks pretty lethal got diagonals
everywhere here here here if I could
draw correct okay
resigned back to tournament four four
four five fours and we've got a couple
of berserkers in there Popeye again this
is pretty early
just try Scandinavian let's see what we
get similar structure as a would see in
a Carol let's drop back once with the 92
move that's a bit mysterious I guess we
go all the way back
let's hit the Queen stop a d5 break I
guess here hmm alright let's pin that
Knight to Queen out again all right
let's take Castle stop Queen here for
sure 95 oh I guess you're planning this
this is a little bit scary I must say
just a little bit hmm
okay this is scary that was a bad move
Knight takes here they made it on c2
okay the night here and it's still not
working
hmm let's just go up one square my
knight could probably be a pain here no
let's take look here could dodge some
checks no I'm on c2 threatened
discoveries that's a check where is the
main
hmm I'm gonna get oh I don't have one
second spent too much time trying to
find something good they could do
whatever really I'm not winning this
yeah they did something sneaky there
they could do whatever oh no time back
to Turman spent too much time trying to
find a kill actually that's a mistake
because I spent too much time worrying
about my dark squares yeah that 'if I
move I think took like 10 seconds that's
too much might as well resign if you're
gonna take 10 seconds on that okay
so where'd I go wrong in that I gave up
my dark square Bishop and I was punished
can't give up your dark square bishop
like that okay let's recover here let's
recover queenside castle that's a
serious weakness now on d6 mmm let's
kick that night out of there and I don't
want a quaint raid night check and then
a night discovery let's go here a night
here next discoveries do I even have a
good one mm I'm go here I want a
queenside castle I could care less about
the structure over here he's a he's a
dumb Bishop anyhow he's no good he's the
bad one he's the bad Bishop of the - so
I'm gonna kick him away Bishop takes I'm
gonna take the knight all right I just
got to go quicker I'll try to find
killer moves all the time
get the a file that night is kicked now
I'm crashing through an a7 it takes 87
I've got a block the bishop take that
one I guess
mmm Bishop check here is real strong
light square bishop exchange make threat
that's mate back to tournament oh I'm
not even on the first page I've do I
have six sixteen sixteen ten ten eight
that's six
I think I read that right all right
let's go here okay I'm taking that pond
and I'm gonna chip away at that pinned
piece okay I'm winning some material I'm
not gonna okay let's get that Queen I
could have taken the night with check
first or just release the Queen here
with e6 secure d5 I think I need some
more ah okay let's get the Queen out
first and then connect it with the
knight on g4 might be five I'm just
gonna let the fork head if that that
happens so I'm gonna do this next you
know I'm fine with that I'm going to
attack the King and this is this is
working rook F 2 is not a defense doctor
Terman 8 still not on first page see
that same loss that happened in the the
last tournament that round 3 loss when
the first to lose that third killer I
got a score 4 points no I also have to
go fast Kappa Hovick okay and now we're
going to save a move at least we're not
gonna move that Bishop twice they're
really gonna go after that see
upon that Queen out of there let's blast
this open all right why not I got this
covered
I'm not afraid should I be Brooksie for
you should be afraid there we go bring
the heat bring the pain
bring the pain Wow hmm
seriously I could take that bishop I
could work my way into a discovered
check
I almost didn't take that Queen fearing
this discovered check it's no bother you
could get away with that
calculate just calculate a little bit
what you trying to get a B to be seven
yeah rook takes pawn Queen here mate
Bishop takes pawn I'm not even up
material at the end of this okay now I
am don't get made it don't get made it
whatever you do okay could go here have
a time edge a pretty good one there we
go
I was ready to drop my rook don't drop
that rook don't drop that rook they're
down on time
back determine had some pressure on them
in that middle game so they burned a lot
of a lot of fuel there a lot of a lot of
seconds 18 16 14 13 12 not going to take
let him struggle some develop every move
every move it's important to avoid the
exchange I would have helped them
develop they might resign no keep moving
forward I've got the rook now and keep
inching forward they resigned back to
the tournament 1818 1816 less than 14
minutes remain
okay Mike Freeman oh we've already
played once okay let's take like this
seek some rapid development yeah why not
mmm
threatening to take and then take here
okay I'm gonna do that if Bishop takes
h2 I'm gonna anchor him in there let's
go here kick the bishop away and then
get back to that square let's defend
first hmm don't they have back rank
issues pretty sure they do sit at h2
giving me that oh its mate actually I
have that square covered back to Turman
I was ready to move my knight to f5 it's
a good thing you didn't because you had
a million one twenty three twenty
eighteen eighteen that was a pretty
quick one sack
of sash Quach Sasquatch Bigfoot
she's calling Bigfoot if you're having
trouble pronouncing its he gonna move
and stalling tactics
look at these stalling tactics we're
revisiting our the same game from our
silo I'm going to delay castling it's
going to make all the difference in the
world when you see that might be so I
have some play on the H file maybe and I
guess in the end I'm gonna do this huh
father Brook was enunciate what are you
doing Wow all right let's take jump in
here huh you're getting there you're
getting there challenge that night 4x on
f7 g6
let's go down that dark square bishop
huh alright another Fork
take the bishop with check they don't
have any time let's just get rid of him
before he hurts you hmm
to watch out for Bishop f5 Wow
miss that lateral movement they don't
have any time back to term in 24 woo 24
23 20
a nail-biter 72 definitely a lot of
players entered from that Eastern bullet
arena that was going on lot of late
joiners for this one nice
all right c5 bring home the point okay
the Knights not there to secure h4 keep
the Queens on develop why is my clock
moving my clock was just moving there
and I had already moved mm-hmm not cool
all right I want to get a grip over this
square don't want it to open up so
quickly and I really grabbed that pawn
let's go here the night takes was a
threat let's secure that okay on push
push
let's see what they do okay let's trade
Queens and let's keep this Bishop Bishop
check I'm not afraid of rooks are now
connected and I could start to get the
tsunami of pawns rolling I really just
want to take that night but let's just
kick them away I'm gonna repeat for just
a little bit let's see if he jumps in
here I'm not afraid of that
okay let's kill the bishop they might
have back rank issues no no you got to
do it oh you got to do it you got to
drop that pawn right here his bishops
cover a lot of squares their bishop is
dead I don't have any time where's my
time
wow that was helpful
that was definitely helpful back to
tournament I do not feel comfortable
with this new Mouse it's just different
it's just different come on man adapt
adapt
okay thirty one twenty eight twenty to
twenty to eight minutes left I don't
think it's necessary to go berserk
throw your knight in to g5 let's keep
the centre closed prepare a sacrifice
here maybe would you are you kidding me
how many times how many times you're
gonna try to move your Bishop to f4
okay g4 is the way to go let's get him
out of there I want to see them take
they're not taking okay
all right now we're smashing things open
avoiding the Queen exchange looking to
attack rook on the G file move the
knight somewhere fast or clean here
forces a queen exchange there goes there
goes that plan
I said that's a good player and realize
who I was playing against okay hmm
take care I could take the knight okay I
don't want to take there Wow
hmm let's take him I guess I wasn't a
good idea by me it was not a good idea
let's grab some material pawn grabber
you pawn grabber you ouch
that's a fork but I have pesky Knights
pesky Knights avoid the trades drop upon
a knight drop Wow fortunately
have a tricky night back to tournament
that was ugly town still in the running
35 32 we need to get paired up and to
kill his fire put out his fire and then
go off okay
Scandinavian mmm-hmm alrighty Queen d2
queenside castle exchange dark square
Bishop I'm not waiting upon here you're
not gonna take that are you might have
seven no and they missed that I guess
let's take that guy out no let's take
something more go in this direction
I'm gonna take my knight okay
enter could've went further let's pin
that night I almost missed that crazy
house tactics crazy house training oh
we're gonna get paired up this game just
finished I think I saw him we switched
places there okay
needless to say this is a big game this
is probably for all the marbles huh no
pressure
nice and easy you have plenty of time a
minute is plenty your bishops having a
fun time getting chased around okay I
thought g4 there you know and I would
have been in some trouble should I offer
a queen trade sure never happened though
I'm going Queen side again Knight b6
they're still gonna
sure let's get here before it's too late
Queen trade I should hit that night
Bishop h6 huh
that's a way to put pressure on your
opponent I'm Bishop g3 okay maybe I get
a g2 I feel like I need to get off of
this diagonal okay it's coming all the
way back that's a really good square
they just gave up they have that move
though huh let's secure him he's
important
my Queens a bit offside yeah let's take
like this I have a huge time lead huge
there you go
get the King towards the center you got
this you got this
I didn't mean to do that okay ah just
what I needed and I could do time
burners they think I'm gonna check their
down on time hmm brought the pressure
brought the heat 40 39 all I need to do
is win this one I think and I'll get it
40 39 32 I don't need to preserve I have
a point lead it's not on streak why am I
playing like this
it's matter with you go for the kill go
for the throat what happened Jerry's
going for the throat no normally likes
Queen trades and all that good stuff he
loves those endings ah throw your rook
opposite the Queen they're not going to
like that it's uncomfortable it's
uncomfortable nest they resigned Wow
oh my goodness it's a good thing too oh
you know what I could always do in this
one I could no no fry my way to Victory
Lane
I just have to use a stalling technique
when in doubt Nonna fry I got this
wrapped up I'll just no no fry my way to
victory we're gonna try to win by
regular means though you know what I
mean
I'll go Queen side if you open up the G
file I can't do that
all right let's bring the pain there we
go there's the pain I was talking about
let's get out of pins hmm this could
hurt let's get definitely hurt this is
going to hurt oh yeah it's gonna hurt
man it's going to hurt yikes
mm-hmm all right I just have to hold off
on me I may have to end up I may have to
known a fry yeah I got a night I got a
night I got a G file where's the fork
where is it where is the fork you still
win this how are we gonna see hmm
in position being attacker there you go
Forks
got the Queen but they're gonna get
another queen nights are tricky nights
are tricky
nights are tricky
got it tricky nights for the win man are
they tricky initially I have to say you
know I I was kind of go for the Nonna
fry I had it in the back of my mind I
think that ruined me I think that that
ruined me
and if you know about Nonna fry some of
you might be like joiners some of you
might be like joiners if you know about
Nonna fry you've been connected with me
for a while let's just say that a lot of
a rollercoaster huh okay where do we
stand here final standings
forty four forty two thirty four twenty
eight twenty six there you go
already there is page 186 players in the
end page one two three four five six
seven eight nine and that'll do it
already to the 86 of you that took part
in the hourly bullet arena good games up
already
you